se trata de una misión científica que se
asemeja en todo a una expedición
un grupo de investigadores franceses y
senegaleses avanza en moto en la sabana
en una especie de villa
tenemos muchas cosas entonces no podemos
andar muy rápido
encabezando detrás del conductor
christophe el aventurero y pat el
doctorado en botánica van al extremo
este de senegal buscan nuevas plantas
que no habrían sido descubiertas aún en
especial nuevas especies de helechos
estos helechos que crecen aparentemente
en altura y relativamente en altura
algunos son desconocidos en senegal
producido
para encontrarlos hay que ir más allá de
los últimos pueblos e ir cada vez más
lejos
a todos ustedes
el objetivo del viaje es este una
cascada muy conservada que no aparece en
ningún mapa
[Música]
es magnífica es verdad
en los lugares más escondidos la
naturaleza aún rebosa de secretos cada
año descubren 2.000 nuevas especies de
plantas en el mundo del fondemi los
acantilados son entornos difíciles de
acceso entonces muy poco alterados y es
muy probable encontrar especies poco
conocidas en senegal y tal vez incluso
una nueva para la ciencia
y estas nuevas especies esperan
encontrarlas en la cascada a christoph y
theo les corresponde la tarea arriesgada
a 70 metros de descenso en rapel
se tiene miedo de caer y luego pues
emoción a precipitación es adrenalina
[Música]
tan solo enganchado a este árbol
christophe se lanza al vacío a lo largo
del descenso recoge especímenes es el
objetivo mismo de la botánica el estudio
de los vegetales lo más cerca posible
[Música]
a los
entonces trato de no recoger tres veces
la misma y todo lo que encuentro nuevo
lo tomo es muy simple es un trabajo
sencillo un poco físico un poco
peligroso pero refrescante también
con torrentes de agua sobre el casco es
difícil discernir cada planta entonces
los dos investigadores recogen todo lo
que ven bajo la supervisión de su colega
que quedó abajo
las bolsas se llenan y es hora de la
zambullida final
[Música]
justo delante de la cascada patel ya
tiene una primera sorpresa
[Música]
es el sueño de todo votan y sta será el
primero en censar una especie para
aumentar los conocimientos sobre los
ecosistemas del planeta y entonces
protegerlos mejor todas las plantas
recogidas son llevadas al laboratorio
para verificación mientras tanto pattern
las ubica con cuidado en su herbario
y los helechos son muy importantes para
nosotros aquí guardarlos con cuidado hay
mucho trabajo por hacer ojalá haya otras
misiones y en otros lugares por explorar
en el siglo 21 la botánica aún tiene con
que sorprendernos según las estimaciones
entre el 10 y el 20 por ciento de la
flora mundial aún no ha sido descubierta
[Música]